toutes les semaines à boulogne
billancourt aux portes de paris
les locaux de cette société voit défiler
une foule d'anonymes des français comme
les autres
accueillis par carole et son collègue
nicolas bonjour comme d'habitude je vous
appelez et je vous laisserai installé en
bas que je vous donnais nous ne sommes
pas dans la salle d'attenté d'un médecin
mais dans les coulisses de l'industrie
alimentaire nicolas et carole travail
pour ce laboratoire un peu particulier
auquel les marques font discrètement
appel pour booster leurs ventes
oui on est dans les temps normalement ce
jour là c'est un fabricant de biscuits
apéritifs qui a besoin de leurs services
car en rayon s'effrite salle et
n'attirent pas les clients manifestement
la recette ne plaît pas donc voilà donc
je commence à préparer ma première
assiette en fait ça est mon assiette
référence alors pour savoir ce qui
cloche
la marque a demandé à nicolas de
comparer ses prix à celle de deux
concurrentes qui eux cartonne en rayon
et pour cela il y un test implacable
celui du consommateur lui-même alors
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
nouvelle séance dégustation donc
aujourd'hui vous allez déguster dans un
premier temps donc trois références de
frites apéritif pensez bien à couper vos
portables ne pas communiquer entre vous
et donc on va être parti avec les frites
une dégustation que l'industriel peut
payer jusqu'à 50000 euros pour certains
tests de grande ampleur voilà je vous
écoute ici en concert le 3 soit
moyennant une petite rémunération de 7
euros la séance
une soixantaine de cobayes vont donc
goûter les fameuses frites un référé 112
pendant vingt minutes ils test à
l'aveuglé en répondant à des questions
très simples pour commencer une note de
1 à 10 puis une appréciation
qu'est ce qui vous a plu et qu'est ce
qui vous a déplu au même moment dans la
pièce d'à côté c'est pauline qui analyse
les premiers résultats
et les nouvelles ne sont pas bonnes pour
son client effectivement ces deux
concurrents des marques d'hypermarchés
s'en sortent beaucoup mieux ou pour
l'instant c'est l'une des tissus fils au
mieux sur une soixantaine de
consommateurs une majorité bout de les
frites apéritif de l'industriel et à
chaque fois c'est la même critique qui
revient
manque un peu de sel pas assez salée
manque de goût et de celle des
commentaires sur lesquelles le fabricant
va pouvoir se baser pour modifier sa
recette et ainsi relancer ses ventes
généralement sur ce type de produits les
critères qui vont ressortir alors le
côté salée puisque ce sont des produits
salés est ce que c'est trop pas assez la
croustillance puisque c'est ce qu'ils
attendent d'un apéritif ça donne des
axes d'amélioration de retravailler aux
industriels quand par exemple leurs
résultats ne sont pas optimum
accrochez toujours plus nos papilles en
ajoutant artificiellement toujours plus
de goût aux produits alimentaires un
enjeu colossal pour les industriels pour
y parvenir les fabricants des secrets et
emploie des méthodes caché que nous
avons découvert et que nous allons vous
dévoiler dans ce document
on ne s'en rend pas toujours compte
quand on est consommateur mais une
poignée d'ingrédients est en train
d'envahir tous nos rayons d arme de
séduction massive que nous mangeons à
haute dose tous les jours et qui ne sont
pas sans conséquences sur notre santé
ces ingrédients tient en trois mots
sucre sel et matières grasses
et peut être l'avez vous remarqué qu'il
s'agisse des plats préparés de la pizza
congelée ou du petit déjeuner lui les
prix baissent et plus le taux de ces
ingrédients grimpe en flèche le sucre
par exemple savez-vous qu'en moyenne
chacun d'entre nous en consomme
l'équivalent de 18 morceaux chaque jour
c'est trois fois plus que ce qui est
recommandé le sel deux fois plus que la
dose raisonnable sans parler des
matières grasses omniprésente sur toutes
les étiquettes
pendant un an nous avons enquêté dans
les coulisses très fermé de l'industrie
alimentaire pour comprendre pourquoi les
fabricants glisse à tout va dans leurs
recettes
jusqu'où ils sont capables d'aller pour
vous donner l'envié d'acheter peut
manger et de manger encore
au bout du compte que risquez-vous à
force de consommer ces produits sans
limite
comment devenons-nous accro aux produits
des géants de l'alimentaire enquête sur
la face obscure de nos plats préférés
[Musique]
pour découvrir la place que prennent ces
ingrédients dans notre quotidien
il suffit de s'inviter dès l'aube au
sein d'une famille comme toutes les
autres
nous sommes dans la banlieue de lyon et
chaque matin de la semaine 17 heures
c'est le branle bas de combat pour
elodie infirmières et son mari farid
vendeur
ilan ilan mais choisir pas le temps de
traîner dans 45 minutes farid watts
emmener les enfants à l'école
alors pour le petit déj dylan et li na 4
et 6 ans ce papa fait au plus pressé
manger quoi ce matin ça oui coco pétales
de maïs blé souffler ou flocons d'avoine
trois fois par semaine ces céréales au
menu les corn flakes les kellogg's si on
choisit à leur place on n'est pas sûr
qu'ils vont aimer et puis généralement
et choisissent par rapport à la boîte un
petit déjeuner que les enfants adorent
et qui arrange bien leurs parents c'est
pratique ça va vite qui a pas les
tartines beurrées et à mettre la
confiture dessus donc voilà pour pas
être en retard à l'école et au travail
accessoires mois la démange kaki comme
90% des petits français
c'est donc avec ces céréales
croustillantes noyé dans un bol de lait
que la journée commence pour ilan
evina parce que c'est sucré c'est parce
que les chiffres du sucre le sucre
omniprésent dans ces céréales il suffit
de se pencher sur l'étiquette
c'est vrai que là quand on garde pour 30
grammes
sachant que lui il a certainement être
en gras mais elle a eu plus - 11 g ça
fait ça fait plusieurs morceaux de sucre
quoi 30 % de sucre dans chaque bol des
le premier repas de la journée
elodie infirmières culpabilise un peu
alors cette jeune maman à une seule
préoccupation tempérer l'appétit de ses
enfants pour le sucre du coup je suis
plus sensibilisés bas au surpoids ou des
leurs enfin je crois
après c'est tellement difficile de
perdre du poids et autant prendre des
bonnes habitudes tout de suite prendre
de bonnes habitudes et freiner la
consommation de sucre un enjeu pour de
très nombreuses familles aujourd'hui
mais une résolution qui n'est pas
toujours facile à tenir notamment quand
on fait ses courses dans les
hypermarchés
il y a un rayon star celui des céréales
du petit déjeuner ici les ventes ont
explosé de 50% en 10 ans parmi la
cinquantaine de pâques est différent on
peut acheter du blé souffler ou des
pétales de maïs et tous regorge de sucre
en moyenne un bol de 30 grammes en
contient 11 g un bon tiers et ça peut
monter beaucoup beaucoup plus haut
derrière toutes ces marques
une poignée de géants de l'alimentaire
pour les plus connus il s'appelle nestlé
kellogg's ou quaker les deux tiers
viennent d'un seul et même pays celui
qui a inventé ce business ou le sucre
est roi alors nous avons voulu savoir
comment en coulisse certaines de ses
marques se livrent une bataille féroce
pour sucrer toujours plus nos céréales
et ainsi faire de nous des
inconditionnels de leurs produits pour
comprendre les dessous de cette
industrie il faut donc se rendre à 8
heures d'avion de paris
bienvenue aux états unis ici chaque
américain consomme en moyenne deux fois
plus de céréales que chez nous à
l'origine de ce best seller il y à une
marque mondialement connue
direction le nord du pays ou une ville
de 50 mille habitants s'est bâti une
solide réputation à travers toute
l'amérique c'est battle creek dans le
michigan la capitale des céréales du
petit d'air une ville pavillonnaire où
sont installés des poids lourds de
l'agroalimentaire
parmi eux certains sont inconnus des
français comme la post company pourtant
ces paquets de golden criss ou de fruity
pebbles se vendent par millions aux
états unis
en revanche une autre firme de battle
creek est célèbre dans toutes les
familles françaises
c'est la kellogg company avec ses cornes
flex yale pop et autres trésors
deux entreprises que nous avons
sollicités elles ont refusé nos demandes
de tournage merci de nous avoir contacté
mais nous n'autorisons aucune caméra
dans nos usines deux empires de la
nourriture industrielle qui ont mis le
sucre au coeur de leurs recettes
une histoire incroyable digne d'un
véritable thriller
une histoire qui a démarré pourtant bien
loin de l'univers de la malbouffe avec
un homme dont le seul but était au
départ de mettre tout un pays au régime
pour découvrir cette histoire étonnante
il faut rendre visite à un homme que
tout battle creek connaît sous le nom de
mr corn flakes
[Musique]
joss stone 86 ans est un inconditionnel
de l'homme à l'origine de ce monument du
petit déjeuner le fameux docteur kellogg
se servir de la maison de john harvey
kellogg gène être s'efface un peu on
peut toujours lire john harvey kellogg
dans sa petite maison cela fait des
années que duff accumule des objets j'ai
pas mal de peluches chose ici aussi
beaucoup ont appartenu à l'inventeur des
célèbres kellogg's corn flakes tué j hkc
l'assiette personnel du docteur kg pour
choper john harvey kellogg est né non
loin de là au milieu du 19e siècle
ce médecin membres de l'église
adventiste va appliquer à la lettre les
principes de sa communauté et notamment
le fait de respecter une hygiène de vie
irréprochable
résultat le docteur kellogg ne fume pas
ne boit pas c'est l'exercice et il est
même végétarien
alors quand il prend la tête du
sanatorium de battle creek il va mettre
ses principes en action gymnastique et
natation pour tous ces patients qui
découvriront également les drôles de
machines de john harvey kellogg comme
cet appareil pour respirer de l'air
frais en dormant ou celui là pour une
séance de luminothérapie avant l'heure
le docteur kellogg déposera au total une
trentaine de brevets pour ses machines
révolutionnaire
ce sera le seul dans ces baignoires la
venue des petits tuyaux pour faire comme
un jacuzzi et parfois ils rajoutaient ce
petit câble pour envoyer un peu
d'électricité aucun noir
et le docteur knock va aussi s'attaquer
à un problème de taille
l'alimentation de ces patients qui le
matin mange un peu trop à son goût
mais à cette époque le petit déjeuner
c'était quelque chose de vraiment lourd
la viande des pommes de terre des tartes
j'aime si les gens travaillent est de
moins en moins manger toujours autant
c'est de là qu'est venue l'idée des corn
flakes dans son hôpital
le docteur va donc concocté du maïs à la
vapeur avant de l'écraser et de le dorer
au four
le résultat les premiers flocons de maïs
les fameux corn flakes john kellogg est
alors loin d'imaginer que quelqu'un va
bientôt profiter de sa recette pour
faire beaucoup d'argent une grande
bagarre commercial est sur le point de
se déclencher
autour d'un ingrédient le sucre car au
fil des mois les patients qui défilent
au sanatorium découvre cette recette
plutôt surprenante
or parmi ces malades il y a un certain
charles ce poste un ingénieur agricole
soigner pour surmenage qui ne va pas se
contenter de goûter cette préparation
maïs il était au sanatorium il fouine
est dans la cuisine
les cuisiniers ont réalisé que non
seulement il jeter un coup d'oeil mais
en plus il prenait des notes sur cette
housse faisait line and child poste bref
de lancer une petite affaire il va
reprendre l'idée du docteur kellogg à
son compte des préparations diététique à
base de céréales
quelques mois plus tard il fonde la
poste compagnie à quelques rues du
sanatorium et lance son premier paquet
les grippes note un mélange de blé et
d'orge
[Musique]
rien de révolutionnaire
sauf qu'en passant les céréales au four
la cuisson à dégager du glucose
ces céréales ont un petit goût sucré les
ventes vont rapidement décollé poste
était loin d'être un imbécile n'avait
pas été là on aurait jamais connu ce
sont des céréales a battle cry
car la réussite de charles ce poste at
il désormais la colère du clan kellogg
en particulier celle du petit frère de
john wilks et l'ogg alors 46 ans et pour
contre attaquer il décide d'ajouter du
sucre dans les céréales de la marque
familiale
[Musique]
il s'agit là d'une véritable déclaration
de guerre lancée à la poste compagnie
mais quand ils kellogg à ajouter du
sucre dans les camps flex les ventes ont
crevé les plafonds
dès lors entre la poste et la kellogg's
le sucre va devenir l'enjeu d'une
bataille commerciale féroce pour
conquérir toujours plus de clients
les années 40 les deux enseignes vont
finir par dominer le marché mondial du
petit déjeuner avec une seule méthode
ajouter du sucre encore et encore
une surenchère qui transparaît jusque
dans les pubs comme celle ci nous sommes
dans les années 50 la poste compagnie
sort ses propres corn flakes le
personnage cornelius un petit épis de
maïs se balade avec son pot de sucre
l'ingrédient va faire un carton auprès
des petits américains
[Musique]
nous sommes sur les rives du lac
supérieur dans le nord des états unis
voici la petite ville de duluth
c'est là que vit un homme qui s'est fait
une spécialité de l'évolution des
céréales
ces 50 dernières années comment ça va
robbery est un collectionneur
particulier car voici ce qu'il conserve
dans sa cave depuis des années venu dans
mon antre dans ce sous sol
rob a accumulé plus de cinq mille boîtes
de céréales un témoignage unique sur
l'évolution de notre petit déjeuner au
fil des générations
rien qu'ici j'ai entre 4000 5000 boîtes
de céréales peut-être plus vous voyez ça
c'est mes préférés ça va des années 20
aux années 80 ce max frosties et corn
flakes
cette collection nous dévoile surtout
comment au fil des décennies les
industriels ont sans cesse rajouter du
sucre attendez vous par là dans cette
collection étonnante prenons l'une des
marques les plus vendues au monde
les froot loops de kellogg's ces petits
ronds multicolores voici la boîte
commercialisé dans les années soixante
dix en déchiffrant l'étiquette on
découvre qu'à l'époque le principal
ingrédient c'est lavoine suivi par le
maïs puis le blé kellogg's a ajouté
ensuite du sucre et voici la même marque
de céréales
aujourd'hui quarante ans plus tard le
sucre est devenu le premier ingrédient
avant les céréales elles mêmes dans
chaque bol on en trouve 12 g
cela fait 40 % de sucre une surenchère
sous la pression de la concurrence celle
de postes bien sûr mais aussi de la
plupart des autres firmes qui au fil des
années ont afflué sur ce créneau des
céréales à l'image de general mills avec
ses cheerios lancé en 1941
à l'époque la version originale toujours
commercialisés contient seulement 1 g 4
% de sucre par bol mais plus la marque
va décliner sa recette de base plus le
taux va exploser
en 1992 dans les cheerios multigrains
par exemple le taux passe à 6 g 20 % de
sucre par bol en 1995 cette version
cheerios glacé fait encore plus fort
avec 12 g 42 % de sucre par bol c'est
dix fois plus que la recette originale
une course au sucre qui s'emballe entre
les différentes firmes et qui va prendre
des proportions gigantesques dans les
années 70 la post company sort cette
marque
les super au ranch crise des céréales
qui contiennent plus de 70 % de sucre
les crises vont faire un véritable
carton
depuis la marque a modifié leur nom et
la recette mais rob reste un nostalgique
de ces céréales hyper sucre est
symbolisé par une petite mascotte a
grimpé chez vous
moi j'ai grandi avec ce petit ourson
sucré ah ça fait longtemps qu'il est là
j'en mange toujours mais j'aime pas le
nouveau nom pour moi c'est toujours des
sugar crise pas seulement à l'époque les
fameux céréales hyper sucre et déclenché
la polémique en 1975 un dentiste inquiet
du nombre de cary chez les enfants
publie une étude reprise dans toute la
presse où il tire la sonnette d'alarmé
les preuves s'accumulent les doses de
sucre sont si importantes qu'il devient
nécessaire de réduire leur concentration
dans la plupart des paquets de céréales
servi au petit déjeuner
la même année jean mayer ce
nutritionniste franco-américain alerte
lui aussi l'opinion en posant cette
question céréales ou bonbons ces
céréales qui contiennent plus de 50 % de
sucre devrait être estampillé comme des
imitations de céréales il faut les
vendre au rayon confiserie et pas dans
celui du petit déjeuner ce coaching
c'est vraiment bon un débat national qui
va avoir des conséquences
car depuis visiblement les fabricants
font tout pour minimiser la présence de
cet ingrédient plus question de faire du
sucre un argument de vente systématique
sur les paquets prenons par exemple
l'une des marques de céréales les plus
connus chez nous laisse max de kellogg's
voilà leonis tracks il suffit de
comparer ce paquet avec celui
commercialisé dans les années 70 à
l'époque il avait marqué sucre
souhaitera ils l'ont remplacé parmi
elles aujourd'hui bien pourquoi ils ont
fait ça sucre au fil du temps c'est
devenu un gros mot est aujourd'hui plus
que jamais alors ils ont enlevé le sucre
ou simplement le mot est fort il y a
toujours 56 % de sucre ils ont enlevé le
mot mais ils ont gardé ingrédients mais
alors à ce stade de notre enquête
une question se pose comment les grands
fabricants décide-t-il du taux de sucre
qu'ils vont mettre dans nos céréales
autrement dit comment les recettes sont
elles élaboré pour en mettre autant
qu'il est possible pour répondre à cette
question nous voici à new york à
quelques kilomètres de manhattan howard
moskowitz 70 en connaît certains des
plus gros secret de l'industrie agro
alimentaire
il y travaille depuis 40 ans un homme
clé pour les grandes marques
là je me souviens c'était le siège de
nestlé vous vous imaginez il ya quarante
ans la première fois que je suis arrivé
ici j'avais 30 ans à peine
j'étais un petit scientifique très
angoissée si à l'époque le géant de
l'alimentaire fait appel à ce jeune
diplômé d'harvard dans psychologie c'est
qu'il est déjà l'un des plus grands
spécialistes de la stimulation du
cerveau humain
en quelques mois howard moskowitz va
réussir à booster les ventes de
l'industriel en attirant les clients
grâce à un nouveau dosage scientifique
des ingrédients pour comprendre son
influence dans nos hypers moskowitz nous
propose de le suivre à l'improviste en
caméra discrète dans un supermarché tout
proche
c'est là que je viens faire les courses
avec ma femme
partout dans les rayons on trouve des
produits auxquels awards le sorcier du
goût a apporté sa touche des conserves
au pis cuit en passant par les paquets
de chips dorilas les doritos
j'ai travaillé dessus jusqu'au rayon
sauce spaghetti ou grâce à lui les
ventes ont explosé en 30 ans là où il
n'y avait qu'une recette dans les années
80 on en compte aujourd'hui plusieurs
dizaines en rayon de la sauce à toutes
les saveurs
quand je suis arrivé sur le marché il
n'y avait rien deux marques tout au plus
regardez aujourd'hui il ya cinq mètres
de rayon
un carton commercial
d'autant que moscovici a ajouté sa
touche personnelle m de plus en plus de
sucre dans le bocal un ingrédient qui à
la base corriger l'acidité de la tomate
et en la matière ses créations pour les
rois des céréales vont battre tous les
records
me souviens j'ai travaillé pour goldman
beaucoup de sucre là aussi pour
rehausser souvenez-vous le goût trop
fade des céréales
le résultat aujourd'hui de véritables
confiserie auquel le consommateur a bien
du mal à résister ça c'est délicieux
aussi honnête mais c'est vraiment comme
les bonbons des succès d'alice
vous appelez ça des bons outils oui
comme des bonbons c'est avec la même
envie terrible de re piocher dedans du
christ vous pouvez même les manger sans
ajouter du lait pour moi c'est ça la
définition d'un bon on vous en parlait
presque comme une drogue qui visitent la
qualif job non pas une drogue
oui si vous aimez vous en redemandez
mais comment rajouter toujours plus de
sucre sans écoeuré le client en 40 ans
de recherche
howard moskowitz a découvert la formule
magique un secret que les plus grandes
marques s'arrachent
d'ailleurs sur le site de sa société
moskowitz n'hésite pas à afficher ses
célèbres clients de coca cola à quaker
en passant par nestlé les rois de
l'agroalimentaire font appel à ses
services
une fois rentré chez lui moskowitz nous
fait découvrir cette formule tous là
c'est de trouver le bon dosage en sucre
pour rendre n'importe quel produit
irrésistible voilà en fait jusqu'à une
certaine quantité vous atteignez ce
qu'on appelle le bliss punk
littéralement le point de féliciter ce
sentiment de plaisir intense que vous
ressentez en dévorant des bonbons par
exemple un dosage en sucre qu'il ne faut
surtout pas dépasser car le plaisir du
client
écoeuré retombe brutalement quand vous
augmenter la dose le plaisir augmente
et puis il rechute et ce sommet ça
s'appelle le bliss pointing c'est très
basique en fait izik veille c'est tout
simple une formule qu'il va appliquer à
la lettre en 2004 avec une marque
inconnue en france mais célèbre aux
etats unis le soda dr pepper qui à
l'époque ne fait plus recette pour le
relancer
moskowitz va calculer scientifiquement
ce fameux bliss poynt en faisant appel à
de gigantesques tests de consommateurs
plus de quatre mille anonymes vont ainsi
goûter une soixantaine d'arômes
différents
leur choix va finalement se porter sur
ce soda version cerise vanille qui fera
un malheur auprès des américains en
réalité un savant dosage de sucre au
gramme près qui varie en général selon
l'âge du client
les enfants par exemple supporter des
quantités bien plus élevés que leurs
parents une donnée avec laquelle
moscovite va faire des merveilles
en travaillant sur des dizaines de
produits et notamment des recettes de
grandes marques de céréales comme par
exemple les golden grahams ou encore
lebron flex de la célèbre post company
quand j'ai travaillé pour la post
company c'était toujours la même
histoire
comment modifier scientifiquement les
céréales et en termes de composition ou
d'ingrédients pour faire en sorte que le
produit est le meilleur groupe possible
pour le consommateur alors parmi tous
les ingrédients que vous devez dosé
est-ce qu'il y en a un qui surpasse les
autres est ce que vous en pensez
c'est à vous de me le dire je déteste le
dire parce que tout le monde connaît la
réponse chez eux que chez eux
je crains une dérive que dénonce
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
nutritionnistes qui pointe du doigt les
conséquences en termes de santé
notamment aux états unis où 35 % des
habitants sont considérés comme obèses
il faut dire qu'en moyenne sans même
s'en rendre compte
les américains consomment l'équivalent
de 22 morceaux de sucre par jour 20% de
plus que les français
cette réalité les géants de
l'alimentaire en sont parfaitement
conscients
lors de notre enquête nous avons
découvert comment dans le plus grand
secret les grandes firmes ont décidé de
se concerter
face à ce qui est devenu un véritable
fléau dans quelques instants sur d8 la
suite de notre enquête dans les
coulisses de l'industrie alimentaire
vous allez découvrir une information à
peine croyable le pouvoir phénoménal du
sucre sur notre cerveau nous allons
aussi vous révéler comment cet
ingrédient permet de diviser par deux le
prix de certaines recettes
a priori ça l'est ont fait manger aux
clients de l'eau des additifs différents
ingrédients qui sont pas qu'ils ont trop
grand chose à faire en fait dans la
recette du bon millions une dérive que
dénonce aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
nutritionnistes qui pointe du doigt les
conséquences en termes de santé
notamment aux états unis où 35 % des
habitants sont considérés comme obèses
il faut dire qu'en moyenne sans même
s'en rendre compte
les américains consomment l'équivalent
de 22 morceaux de sucre par jour 20% de
plus que les français
cette réalité les géants de
l'alimentaire en sont parfaitement
conscients
lors de notre enquête nous avons
découvert comment dans le plus grand
secret les grandes firmes ont décidé de
se concerter
face à ce qui est devenu un véritable
fléau
[Musique]
c'est l'un des journalistes les plus
respectés du new york times qui en a
obtenu la preuve
michael moss est devenue en quelques
années la bête noire des plus grandes
marques
après une première enquête sur la viande
récompensé par le prestigieux prix
pulitzer il a levé le voile dernièrement
sur les pratiques des industriels pour
vendre toujours plus de leurs produits
voilà j'ai cherché à comprendre comment
les géants de l'alimentaire nous rendent
à gros ça c'est la version américaine de
monde un best-seller retentissant sur
les coulisses de la malbouffe repris
dans les journaux du monde entier
dans cet ouvrage michael moss le
certifie ces grandes firmes sont tout à
fait conscientes de mettre en danger la
santé de leurs consommateurs
pour preuve le journaliste commence son
livre par le récit d'une réunion jusque
là tenu secret
nous sommes le soir du 8 avril 1999 au
31e étage de cet immeuble de minneapolis
les onze pdg des plus grandes
multinationales de l'alimentaire se sont
donné rendez-vous dans la plus grande
discrétion
les patrons de coca cola mars où kraft
se bagarre toute l'année dans les rayons
au travers de cette galaxie de marque
vendus dans nos hypers
ce soir là pourtant tous ont répondu à
l'invitation du patron de kraft foods
michael mode voici le texte de son
intervention que s'est procuré le
journaliste le pdg s'alarme de
l'explosion de l'obésité en amérique
avant tout on ne peut pas prétendre que
la nourriture et l'obésité ne sont pas
liés aucun expert digne de ce nom
n'attribue l'explosion de l'obésité au
simplement d'exercice
michael mode évoque la crainte de procès
comme ceux qui frappent à l'époque les
géants du tabac
il invite les autres pdg à inverser la
tendance
il est certain que le pire que nous
pourrions faire c'est justement de ne
rien faire
mais à peine terminé cet appel va être
balayé d'un revers de main par l'un de
ses concurrents
le patron le plus puissant du secteur à
l'époque d'après trois participants
interrogés par michael moss tous les
regards se tournent alors vers stefan
singer le pdg de general mills se lève
et l'air mécontent s'adresse à michael
mode
il refuse de modifier ses produits il a
dit ce que la plupart des gens dans la
salle pensaient tout bas
[Musique]
on rend déjà suffisamment de compte aux
consommateurs puis ou ans au pire mais
n'oubliez jamais que nous sommes surtout
responsable auprès de nos actionnaires
et il n'est pas question pour nous de
mettre en rayon des produits que
personne ne va acheter
et voilà pourquoi à l'issue de cette
réunion secrète
les géants de l'alimentaire vont
maintenir les produits tels qu'ils les
ont élaborées
des révélations que le patron de general
mills de l'époque stefan singer n'a
jamais démenti
les industriels refusent donc de lever
le pied avec le sucre alors que déjà à
ce moment là le fléau de l'obésité est
en train de se répandre dans la société
américaine et notamment chez les enfants
et les adolescents des millions de
jeunes clients marqué dès le berceau par
la sensation de plaisir que procure cet
ingrédient
enjoy regardez cette étude sur les bébés
en observant leurs impressions un pays
on voit bien qu une saveur aigre par
exemple ça les fait grimacer le goût
amer c'est pire et regardez le sucre et
regarder le visage de ce bébé s il est
submergé dans le plaisir des enfants
attiré très tôt par le sucre il faut
débarquer à la table du petit déjeuner
dans une famille américaine pour voir
comment au fil des années les grands
noms du secteur sont parvenus ainsi à
fidéliser des millions de clients dès
leur plus jeune âge pour cela nous nous
sommes rendus au sud de new york à
baltimore où chaque matin c'est le même
cérémonial pour la famille badowski
caitlin knight et leurs trois bambins
alors les enfants à qu'est ce que vous
voulez pour le collège dans cette maison
chacun sait parfaitement ce qui lui fera
le plus plaisir
pour les parents c'est un grand
classique du petit déjeuner américain
le frenchy tos le toast à la française
du pain de mie trempé dans un mélange 9
et de l'est que kateline fait frire à la
poêle du pain perdu
avec en plus des oeufs brouillés
seulement voilà pas question pour
quelques lignes de passer son samedi
matin à cuisiner et ça tombe bien car le
petit déjeuner des enfants est bien plus
rapide à préparer
quand je suis fatigué de préparer des
oeufs ou des toasts je n'ai qu'à jeter
quelques serial dans un bol et c'est
beaucoup plus facile et des céréales
dans le placard de la cuisine kitchen en
a pour tous les goûts et tous les âges
[Musique]
on a des cheerios des céréales à la
cannelle et des fraudes loops on en a
aussi au miel et d'ailleurs ce sont les
préférés de mon mari le petit gavin lui
n'a d'yeux que pour ces froot loops du
matin
de drôles de céréales multicolores qui
font un carton aux états unis chez tous
les jeunes enfants même élevé c'est fait
avec des fruits non ça n'a même pas le
goût de fruits d'ailleurs ils sont juste
coloré et c'est rigolo des anneaux
colorés qui font chaque matin le délice
du petit garçon si je l'écoutais et leur
prendrait quatre ou même cinq fois et
pendant que gavin se gavent de fautes
loops laura sa grande soeur se régale de
ses céréales aux noix et au miel mes
préférés c'est léo nenad cherrios c'est
vrai ce sont tes préférées
mais pourquoi tu les aimes bien ouais
nico mas qu'elles sont jolies et sucrée
de jolies couleurs mais surtout ce goût
sucré qui semble faire le régal des deux
petits kateline n'a d'ailleurs qu'à
jeter un coup d'oeil au paquet pour
constater que ces céréales regorge de
sucre 12 g
dans un bol de 29 g plus du tiers du
petit déjeuner de chaque enfant est
constitué de sucre mais cela ne semble
pas vraiment posé de problème à cette
maman je m'en fiche un peu je préfère
mais serial au sucre à la fesci
nutritionnelle et en même temps il ya du
fer de la vitamine
ça pourrait être pire mais si ces
céréales cartonne autant ce n'est pas
qu'une question de gourmandise il y a
une autre explication plus inquiétante
il s'agit d'une information à peine
croyable le pouvoir addictif du sucre
ont un pouvoir d'accoutumance
considérable dont vous allez découvrir
les effets
cette révélation étonnante c'est un
français qui en est à l'origine
directeur de recherche au cnrs nous
l'avons retrouvé dans son laboratoire de
l'université de bordeaux où il travaille
son nom serge ahmed l'un des plus grands
spécialistes au monde des addictions
un scientifique réputé pourtant ces
découvertes
il l'a fait presque par hasard depuis
plus de 20 ans serge ahmed étudient
notamment les effets des drogues sur ces
rats albinos des expériences pour
comprendre comment fonctionne la drogue
sur le cerveau humain
en effet ces animaux sont très proches
de nous laura comme l'un lorsqu'il est
exposé une drogue
il est sensible à ces effets
récompensant et donc du coup il va
chercher à reproduire l'expérience par
son comportement
or ces rats par exemple ont une
particularité les expériences de serge
ahmed les ont rendues totalement accro à
la cocaïne
il faut dire que le chercheur leur en
administre depuis des semaines sont des
animaux qui ont développé une addiction
aux drogues et donc on peut les
considérer comme des toxicomanes des
rats devenu cocaïnomane mais en 2007 au
cours d'une expérience sert jamais tu
vas faire une découverte incroyable une
drogue encore plus puissante que la
cocaïne
et pourtant surprise on la trouve
partout et vous en consommez au
quotidien et voici donc la fameuse
expérience
audrey l'assistante prépare de liquide
dans cette première seringue de la
cocaïne diluée dans une seconde seringue
audrey va mélanger de l'eau et cette
poudre blanche du saccharose
autrement dit du sucre les deux liquides
vont être proposés aux rats
les animaux là que nous testons n'ont ni
soif ni fin ils sont logés dans des
cages avec de la nourriture et de la
boisson à volonté
donc le ce qui les motive c'est la
recherche du plaisir leur a donc le
choix entre deux tuyaux donc celui de
gauche est associée donc à l'eau sucrée
et celui de droite associé à la coquille
souvenez-vous serra sont accros à la
drogue il en consomme
dès qu'ils en ont l'occasion ils
lorsqu'ils accueillent cocaïne en fait
la consomme d'une même pendant des
heures et pourtant alors que le rat
commence par se diriger vers la cocaïne
à droite ils changent subitement
direction et vire à gauche vers le tuyau
d'eau sucrée l'aï moi donc là vous voyez
tous les petits mouvements en fait c'est
sa langue à leur à se précipitent avec
gourmandise sur le sucre et quel que
soit l'animal ce choix se confirme dans
90% des cas
un choix qui stupéfait serge ahmed
nous cherchons à démontrer la puissance
addictives de la drogue et c'était la
cocaïne à l'époque et en fait nous avons
découvert la puissance addictives du
sucre a été surprise et nous avons été
très surpris et d'ailleurs beaucoup ont
encore du mal à croire à ce résultat
d'accord même si maintenant il est bien
reproduits répliqué dans plusieurs
laboratoires pour le chercheur pas de
doute le sucre agit comme une drogue
pour le cerveau
mais ce que l'on sait par exemple chez
les fumeurs qui essayent d'arrêter
on sait que la plupart qu'ils
s'abstiennent en fait sur rabat sur la
nourriture est d'ailleurs prennent
beaucoup de poids et les nourriture
qu'ils consomment en fait c'est surtout
des nourritures riches en sucre le sucre
huit fois plus addictif que la cocaïne
cette découverte sert jamais tu vas donc
la publier dans l'une des plus grandes
revues scientifiques au monde
plos one avec un titre en forme de
révélation
le sucre est intense plus fort que la
cocaïne sur quinze pages le chercheur y
fait état de ses découvertes et en guise
de conclusion
voici ce qu'il écrit
la stimulation de nos récepteurs
sensoriels par un régime riche en sucres
développerait un signal de récompenses
hors normes dans notre cerveau
conduisant à l'addiction
évidemment en aucun cas le sucre n'est
dangereux comme la cocaïne peut l'être
mais la découverte de serge ahmed a fait
l'objet de nombreuses reprises dans la
presse jusqu aux états unis il faut dire
que le pouvoir du sucre et la
consommation à haute dose qu'il peut
engendrer est loin d'être sans
conséquences sur notre santé
aujourd'hui des maladies se développent
en lien direct avec cet ingrédient est
l'une d'entre elles est en train de
faire de véritables ravages en france
[Musique]
chaque mois c'est dans cet immeuble
parisien que marc 52 ans a rendez vous
il vient consulter un spécialiste de la
nutrition
bonjour madame j'ai rendez vous avec le
docteur allouche a priori pourtant ce
prof de musique a l'air plutôt en bonne
santé
en réalité il ya un an il a appris qu'il
avait du diabète comme 3 millions de
français marc à un excès de sucre dans
le sang une maladie sans symptômes
apparents mais qui peut entraîner de
graves complications et nécessitent
souvent les fameuse piqûre d'insuline la
fin de votre tour de taille
à chaque rendez vous pour suivre
l'évolution de sa maladie
le docteur prend une mesure toute simple
docteur vous ne faisait pas non non je
vous fais pas parce qu'au fond le point
m'intéresse moins que le tour de taille
en fait il faut comprendre que on
soupçonne les cellules qui sont là dans
l'abdomen et au tour de l'abdomen d'être
responsable en fait du diabète et des
maladies cardiovasculaires et là on est
à 86 vous souvenez vous étiez je crois
que c'était 89 3 centimètres perdus en
menant une vie plus saine en faisant du
sport et surtout en tirant un trait sur
tous les aliments sucrés que marc
engloutit s'est auparavant
à commencer par ses céréales préférées
avant quand je prenais mes méthodes qui
déjeune et je me faisais plaisir
sagna au niveau des céréales comme ça de
ce type là des céréales qui contiennent
plus de 86 grammes de glucide la grande
famille des sucres une source d'énergie
pour l'organisme le souci c'est que les
industriels ont donc tendance à en
rajouter plus que de raison quand vous
lisez une étiquette les glucides c'est
l'ensemble des sucres et les sucres
c'est ce qu'on appelle les sucres
simples parce que c'est le sucre qu'on a
ajouté à la préparation il faut savoir
qu'en france 70% des sucres que vous
consommez ne sont pas des sucres que
vous avez volontairement ajouté ce sont
des sucres qui sont inclus dans des
préparations industrielles ont des
boissons sucrées beaucoup de sucres
ajoutés
voilà ce qui pourrait expliquer
l'explosion du diabète une maladie
incurable et sournoise qui peut mettre
dix ans a touché les reins les yeux ou
le coeur des malades qui deviennent
accros au sucre sans même s'en
entretenir dès qu'on commence à manger
un peu plus sucré bas 1 2 heure après on
a faim et on a envie de nouveau de
manger du sucre est pourquoi le sucre
appelle le sucre tout simplement parce
qu quand on a l'habitude dans l'enfance
par exemple d'être récompensé par du
sucre avec des quantités importantes
on va essayer de renouveler l'expérience
de plaisir en consommant ce sucre
l'idée c'est pas diaboliser le sucre
c'est tout simplement de dire que le
sucre a un effet d'une puissance
incroyable sur notre cerveau résultat en
dix ans seulement le nombre de personnes
diabétiques a doublé en france
d'ailleurs l'agenda du docteur est plein
plusieurs semaines à l'avancé
de plus en plus de patients qui viennent
consulter pour diabète d'abord parce que
mangent de plus en plus de produits
industriels
les gens font moins leurs courses
cuisine - mangent plus à l'extérieur on
continue à manger des produits qui sont
chargés en selle chargé reçu chercher en
grèce donc c'est vraiment aujourd'hui
une maladie d'actualité en cent ans la
consommation de sucre est ainsi monté en
flèche merci docteur on va bientôt en
1900 chaque français absorbé
l'équivalent de quatre morceaux par jour
aujourd'hui c'est 18 morceaux au
quotidien le sucre un ingrédient que
l'on consomme de plus en plus on en
trouve absolument partout dans notre
alimentation est le plus étonnant c'est
que les industriels n'en met pas
seulement dans des préparations sucrées
mais aussi dans des recettes salées qui
en principe ne contiennent pas de sucre
notre enquête nous conduit non loin de
marseille
c'est là à vitrolles qui est installé
depuis quatre générations
l'un des plus gros négociants français
de sucre dans le sud de la france quand
une marque veut sucrer l'une de ses
recettes c'est en général à jean charles
banny ce qu'elle s'adresse
car cet ingrédient il en vend sous
toutes les formes dans ce bocal par
exemple du sucre de canne qui vient tout
droit de l'île maurice
c'est un sucre c'est un sucre roux c'est
vraiment le le jus qu'à un sucre qui a
été réduit au maximum ça sert à faire
les spéculoos du prix c'est plus cher
que le sucre blanc le sucre blanc
de base de cristal de base c'est ce qu'à
deux suspects
le moins cher le sucre blanc n'ont pas
issu de la canne mais de la betterave
dans le nord de la france un sucre à
tout petit prix
jean charles banny sva le facturer à ses
clients seulement 50 centimes d'euro du
kilo sa meilleure vente
voyez brûlé un petit peu c'est du sucre
cristallisé c'est du très sale numéro 2
ces cristaux encore dans le broyeur ils
vont éclater et faire vraiment une
poudre extrêmement fine une poudre sucre
est que les industriels affectionne
aussi car ils peuvent en glisser dans
toutes leurs recettes sans que l'on s'en
rende vraiment compte
on ne saurait pas qu'il est dans votre
produit mais il sera quasiment dans
toutes les têtes des fabrications
pourtant le saura pas pourquoi vous le
saurez pas parce qu'une fois que la
fonte du résultat monsieur banny
s'expédient jusqu'à 20 tonnes de sucre
par jour ses clients des géants du
biscuit de la confiserie mais aussi des
industriels du salé qui utilisent cet
ingrédient devenu incontournable
derrière vaud il ya une palette qui
offre un transformateur de
de crustacés puisqu'il va faire durer
ces services au sud pour faire la
réparation que ses preuves et 750 tout
le monde s'en sert tout le monde en
mange tout le monde en tournant
l'absorbent sans savoir
et voilà donc comment l'essentiel du
sucre que l'on consomme tous les jours
se retrouvent dans notre assiette à
notre insu cachés dans nos produits de
tous les jours
carte pour les rois de la nourriture
industrielle c'est l'ingrédient pas cher
qui peut faire des miracles et surtout
dans les plats salés
parmi les vedettes du rayon prenez par
exemple un grand classique de la
gastronomie le boeuf bourguignon
derrière le magret de canard les moules
frites ou encore le couscous c'est l'un
des dix plats préférés des français
dans les rayons on le propose mitonné
doucement avec ses pommes de terre ou
encore aux vins de bourgogne
en regardant les photos sur les
étiquettes tous semblent aussi bons les
uns que les autres
seulement les prix vont du simple au
double 2 6 euros 48 à près de 15 euros
le kilo
alors comment expliquer de tels écarts
et surtout est-il possible que dans ce
plat salé
l'industriel y mette du sucre pour
élaborer un produit à prix cassés
[Musique]
nous avons bien essayé d' enquêter chez
ces fabricants mais sans succès aucun
d'entre eux n'a accepté nous ouvrir ses
portes à chaque fois nous nous sommes
heurtés à la même réponse plutôt
expéditive
[Musique]
d'abord je voulais juste parler des
compositions des d'accord pour portel
raison alors pour découvrir leurs
méthodes
nous avons fait comme des millions de
consommateurs nous avons ouvert ses
boîtes et l'envers de la recette nous a
réservé bien des surprises pour dévoiler
les secrets de ce plat discount nous
nous sommes rendus non loin de dijon au
coeur de la bourgogne
christian charvet et ses amis sont
membres de la confrérie gastronomique
locale des incollables de la recette
originale on va y aller doucement
et vous allez voir que même à l'aveuglé
tous vont rapidement identifié une
grosse différence entre les deux boeuf
bourguignon que nous leur apportons ce
jour là dans cette première casserole
une grande marque vendue en hiver 15
euros le kilo
dans la seconde la version à prix cassés
vendu 7 euros le kg seulement
alors c'est 200 m2 différents pour
commencer et sans qu'il le sache nous
leur faisons goûter la recette de la
marque deux beaux morceaux de boeuf
quelques petits légumes et une sauce à
base de vin rouge de bourgogne
la viande a l'air de qualité à l'air
moelleuse c'est beau ça se tient fait la
sauce c'est plus joli
la sauce a l'air assez onctueuse et elle
est correcte
je suis bien à lui vraiment mignon
christian et ses confrères gouttes
maintenant la version discount de ce
grand standard de la cuisine française
et au premier coup d'oeil
il y a déjà une grosse différence peu de
viande et beaucoup de garniture il ya
beaucoup de légumes essentiellement 10
la viande et par 13 à ce titre il n'est
pas manchot
donc c'est pas engageant un boeuf
bourguignon moins appétissants et qui à
la dégustation va réserver une drôle de
surprise à ses habitués la sauce est
plus sucrée sastre elle sent pas
tellement le vin a retrouvé à sucre et
un petit goût de ketchup et de sucré
voilà ce que c'est gourmet ont détecté
étrange pour une recette qui a priori
est entièrement salé alors y aurait-il
vraiment du sucre et si oui pour quelles
raisons
les carottes des composés c'est un peu
dommage ces recettes industriels n'ont
plus aucun secret pour cet homme
vous ne le connaissez peut-être pas
pourtant vous avez déjà certainement
goûter ses créations luc lescaut est
cuisinier c'est surtout l'un des
consultants les plus recherchés par les
grandes marques de l'agroalimentaire
c'est lui qui aide les fabricants à
élaborer les fameux plats cuisinés
discount que vous achetez en
hypermarchés ce matin là justement il
travaille sur un boeuf bourguignon à
petit prix le tarif doit être imbattable
moins de 3 euros du kilo deux fois moins
cher qu'une grande marque
alors quels ingrédients va-t-il donc
utilisée pour commencer
luc l'escaut s'attaque toujours à la
viande donc on est sur des morceaux en
gros qu'ils vont faire entre 50 et 70 g
cette viande c'est de la vache laitière
bien moins coûteuse que celle utilisée
dans la recette classique issu de races
à viande
celle ci est deux fois moins cher
d'ailleurs le cuisinier ne s'en cache
pas c'est loin d'être de la première
qualité et emmenés sur une fille moins
de viande qu'ils être extrêmement sèches
et très filandreuse le problème
maintenant pour lui que lescot c'est
quand cuisant ces beaux morceaux vont
réduire de taille et perdre de leur
poids et la viande
c'est ce qui coûte le plus cher dans la
recette pas question d'en perdre un seul
gramme alors luc l'escaut va lui faire
subir un traitement très spécial on va
préparer notre entre guillemets marinade
si le consultant mets des guillemets
c'est que les ingrédients qu'il va
utiliser n'ont rien de bien appétissant
tancés nitrites et première action
deuxième action le sel fin de sorte de
sel
mais surtout c'est drôle de poudre
blanche c'est ce qu'on appelle des
rhéteurs dos car dans cette pub luc
l'escaut va rajouter un bon litre d'eau
à ses morceaux de boeuf avant de malaxer
le tout de longues minutes ont fait
manger aux clients de l'eau des additifs
différents ingrédients qui sont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas grand chose à faire en
fait dans la recette du bourguignon
mais cette technique est très utile aux
industriels allez on va se faire plaisir
l'opération va permettre d'augmenter à
peu de frais le poids de la viande dans
la recette on est dans la phase on va
dire économique
je travaille ma viande je lui fait boire
je lui fait absorber différents et
n'ayant de manière à ce que au global
une fois terminé mon produit ali en a
limité la perte de poids sur la matière
qu'est la plus chère est à dire la
protéine animale
au final voilà le résultat l'eau a
totalement disparu de la cuve elle est
maintenant dans la viande
toute l'eau a été absorbée par la viande
en quoi
combien de temps on va dire à les trois
quarts d'heure pour l'industriel c'est
tout bénef
il se retrouve au final avec plus de
viande qu'au début et pour le même prix
on a acheté un kilo et on met à cuire 1
kg 2 donc tous bien le problème c'est
qu'une fois traité c'est tout la viande
n'a plus grand chose à voir avec les
morceaux de départ et même en y ajoutant
la garniture des carottes et des petits
oignons surgelés
la mixture est loin de ressembler encore
à du boeuf bourguignon
alors on a une viande qui est nature
toute nature on peut pas avoir elle n'a
pas subi de marinade dans son bain rouge
elle n'a pas été colorée alors pour
transformer cette préparation recettes
appétissantes
le chef l'escaut va jouer les apprentis
sorciers pour commencer un peu de
concentré de tomate le concentré de
tomate tout simplement de la couleur une
pointe d'acidité et une notes
aromatiques
puis cette poudre rose du vin déshydraté
voilà c'est vrai que ça fait pas très
culinaire mais pour donner de l'éclat à
la recette surprise l'udc les secours va
avoir recours à un ingrédient totalement
absent de la recette originale le sucre
à commencer par ce qui est couramment
utilisé dans la pâtisserie le caramel il
peut être caramel rien de tel pour
donner à la viande un petit goût de fumé
comme si elles avaient été brisées une
technique de cuisson qui aurait augmenté
les coûts toc
là encore une fois en haut niveau
économique on est gagnant sur tous les
tableaux
luc l'escaut n'a plus qu'à rajouter un
peu d'eau et mettre à cuire
mais pour relever le goût du plat à la
garniture un peu fade
le chef va glisser dans la recette le
plus efficace des boosters de goût du
sucre là encore celui que nos gourmet
avait détecté dans la recette le sucre
va gonfler les arômes des autres
ingrédients et pour presque rien
la fois le sucre va révéler le bout des
carottes
si elles ne sont pas suffisamment sucré
et puis comme on travaille une sauce au
vin une sauce au vin par habitude de les
gens estiment que ça doit toujours avoir
une petite note sucrée ne serait-ce
qu'un à finition mais il reste un
dernier souci cette mixture n'a pas
encore la couleur d'un vrai boeuf
bourguignon comme en rêvent les
consommateurs ils risqueraient d'être
déçus alors pour parfaire l'illusion le
chef va se mettre aux fourneaux dans ce
saladier
il mélange du chocolat de l'épée 6 ans
et un peu plus de 20 en poudre voilà
donc là on va mettre l'eau une fois
mélangés cela donne cette pâte marron
que l'udc l'escaut n'a plus qu'à verser
dans sa marmite pour obtenir ce qui
ressemble bien davantage à une recette
gastronomique est donc là le tour est
joué
on a une osmose complète viande légumes
liaison tout est homogène et voilà donc
comment les industriels incorpore sans
que nous le sachions toutes sortes de
sucre dans des recettes salées pour
pouvoir fabriquer ses plats discount
beaucoup moins cher que les grandes
marques
la différence on est sur un produit on
peut diviser par deux largement
largement par deux que ce soient
dissimulées dans les recettes ou non le
sucre est aujourd'hui de plus en plus
présent dans notre alimentation
chaque français en consomme 100 grammes
en moyenne chaque jour un business
colossal qui rapporte trois milliards et
demi d'euros de chiffre d'affaires par
an à ceux qui le fabriquent
alors pour s'assurer que les ventes
continuent de grimper
les industriels utilisent des armes
redoutables pour séduire les
consommateurs les plus sensibles c'est à
dire les plus jeunes d'entre nous
[Musique]
ce jour là à paris devant la cathédrale
notre dame on célèbre la fête du pain
pour des centaines de curieux
c'est l'occasion de découvrir le travail
des artisans boulangers dans une
ambiance de kermesse
on vous souhaite à toutes et à tous une
bonne fête du pain une vingtaine de
stands consacrés aux pins où chacun peut
mettre la main à la pâte pour fabriquer
sa propre baguette des badauds des
touristes mais aussi beaucoup de groupes
scolaires de passage dans la capitale
qui souhaite toujours wenger
mais quel rapport entre cette fête du
pain et le sucre justement aucun a
priori car nous l'avons vérifié il n'y a
pas un gramme de sucre dans une baguette
c'est quand les ingrédients dans la
manière en touche
faris l eau le dur le vin est pourtant
surprise ce jour là le temps de la
cuisson les écoliers vont tous se
diriger vers un stand qui rencontre un
sacré succès chez les plus jeunes
[Musique]
distribution à volonté de par ba papa
alors évidemment c'est l'affluence ce
stand c'est celui du lobby du sucre en
france les plus gros fabricants du
secteur
d'ailleurs la dame est clairement là
pour faire la promotion de cet
ingrédient auprès des enfants et de la
maîtresse
mais vous savez combien il ya des sucres
là un morceau de succès que 5 g
donc là j'ai combien de grammes de 600
grammes par manon 10 grammes c'est non
plus joindre à nous plus ni la g2 gravol
mon dieu quelle horreur
j'étais loin une promo pour gommer la
mauvaise image du sucre car derrière
c'est toute une filière qui prospère
on est loin de ce spot dans les années
[Musique]
c'était la grande époque où ce secteur
pouvaient ouvertement faire la pub de
son ingrédient fétiche à la manoeuvre
les producteurs de betteraves à sucre
dans le nord de la france le sucre le
plus petit des grands bézy trente ans
plus tard face aux inquiétudes le lobby
se montrent plus discret néanmoins il
reste actif comme ici à la fête du pain
dégustation de confiserie suivie d'une
séance de cinéma après la barbe à papa
les enfants sont en effet dirigé vers
une salle de projection juste à côté
pour y voir un film promotionnel sur le
sucre des sketches qui parle de
l'alimentation et qu'ils adressent des
messages subtils pour redorer l'image du
sucre de plus en plus décrié journée d
après le match qu'ils vont bon train
difficile donc de résister à cet
ingrédient qui procure autant de douceur
et autant de plaisir et qui surtout tous
le goût de n'importe quel aliment mais
pour les industriels
la magie du sucre est loin d'être
suffisante pour attirer les clients en
masse vers leurs produits car pour
capter le maximum de consommateurs les
fabricants aujourd'hui se livrent une
bataille des prix sans merci dans les
rayons pour y parvenir il mise tout sur
un ingrédient redoutable un ingrédient
qui permet de faire chuter les prix un
ingrédient que nous avalons tous en
grande quantité au quotidien c'est la
matière grasse un aliment qui comporte
des risques pour notre santé et pourtant
les français en mangent 28 kg chaque
année ses vingt pour cent de plus qu'il
ya dix ans et ce n'est pas prêt de
s'arrêter
car en coulisses certains sont en train
de tout mettre en oeuvre pour que sans
que vous le sachiez vous en mangez plus
encore dans quelques instants sur d8 la
suite de notre enquête sur la face
cachée de nos plats préférés vous allez
découvrir comment certains industriels
ont bâti de véritables empires sur le gr
un ingrédient à la mauvaise réputation
pourtant sous toutes les formes il
envahit nos rayons
ici s'agisse de matières grasses en
paillettes ça peut être dans les
bouillons cube ça peut être dans les
soupes en poudre ça peut être dans
certaines applications de kish de pizza
ou d'autres choses
pour casser les prix les fabricants
misent tout sur un ingrédient redoutable
un ingrédient que nous avalons tous en
grande quantité au quotidien cet
ingrédient c'est la matière grasse un
aliment qui comporte des risques pour
notre santé et pourtant les français en
mangent 28 kg chaque année ses vingt
pour cent de plus qu'il ya dix ans et ce
n'est pas prêt de s'arrêter
car en coulisses certains sont en train
de tout mettre en oeuvre pour que sans
que vous le sachiez vous en mangez plus
encore
nous sommes en belgique dans la banlieue
de liège
c'est dans cette belle demeure que vie
philippe thierry 55 ans là on a sorti au
boulot chaque matin pour rejoindre son
usine cet industriel monte dans sa
bentley
monsieur thierry est à la tête d'une
petite fortune car sans le savoir vous
avez forcément acheter et consommer son
produit phare en faisant vos courses
et voilà donc ce business bâti dans les
coulisses de l'agroalimentaire une
entreprise familiale fondée par son
grand-père il y à 80 ans
bonjour philippe thierry c'est un peu
monsieur gras car tout son business
repose sur la matière grasse il en vend
pour 45 millions d'euros chaque année
ses clients des grandes marques
françaises et étrangères des industriels
qui lui passe commande pour mettre du
gras dans la recette ici s'agit de
matières grasses en fayette
ça peut être dans les bouillons cube ça
peut être dans les soupes en poudre ça
peut être dans certaines applications de
de kish de pizza ou d'autres choses mais
voici sa meilleure vente 70% de sa
production de gros blocs de grès 10
kilos chacun destinés par exemple au roi
du goûter pour leurs biscuits pendant la
préparation du biscuit le biscuitier va
préparer son pétrissage pour faire une
pâte la pâte peut servir à faire des
gosses à faire des biscuits à faire des
gâteaux affecté ces blocs de grès ce
n'est pas du beurre mais de la margarine
le gras le plus répandu dans nos plats
favoris utilisés par exemple dans 70%
des biscuits contre 30% pour le beurre
c'est la fameuse matières grasses
d'origine végétale que l'on trouve sur
nos étiquettes en rayon un produit à
l'histoire étonnante inventé en 1869 à
l'époque l'empereur napoléon iii lance
un grand concours pour inventer un
produit semblable au beurre aussi gras
et nutritifs mais moins cher pour que
les français les plus pauvres puissent
en acheter
et c'est un pharmacien hippolyte meije
mouriès qui va gagner le concours avec
sa margarine
à la différence du beurre fait à partir
de lait de vache sa trouvaille est tout
simplement un mélange de graisses
végétales avec un peu d'eau plutôt
basique en apparence mais voilà philippe
thierry dois t'adapter se mélangent aux
exigences de chacun de ses clients
un vrai casse tête pour guy sont
responsables de recherche
bonjour bonheur ce matin là justement
ces équipes ont dû retravailler une
margarine pour un fabricant de 300
industriels
l'ingrédient était trop dure et ne font
des pas dans la recette la marque attend
une margarine plus molle lors de la
fabrication de ses croissants la
magazine ne s'étalait pas ne suivait pas
la pâte comme elle aurait dû le faire et
ça conduit à des croissants qui
n'étaient pas suffisamment fait qu est
ici nous sommes manifestement dans la
bonne direction
on introduit et souple plastique souple
pour obtenir cette margarine plus
malléable guy et ses équipes ont dû
jouer sur un savant dosage entre
différentes huiles végétales comme dans
la majorité des magazines de feuilletage
trois chambres on est ici sur des
fractions de palme sur du palm et de
l'huile de colza
un cocktail d'huiles car vous allez le
voir dissimulés dans nos plats préférés
ces graisses ont des propriétés parfois
très différentes
philippe thierry l'ait fait venir du
monde entier plusieurs fois par jour
elles débarquent par camion citerne dans
la cour de l usine d huile de toutes
sortes importés de l'étranger depuis le
port de rotterdam tout proche
voilà aujourd'hui on est au quatrième
camion de la journée on a su un camion
colza raffiné un camion d'huile de palme
et un camion trop arty voilà pour le
début de la matinée d'aujourd'hui les
huiles végétales avec lesquels philippe
thierry va pouvoir faire du sur mesure
pour les industriels de l'alimentaire 10
sont responsables de recherche est
justement en train de mettre au point
une recette pour un de leurs clients
fabricants de glaces en hypermarchés il
doit choisir une huile pour
confectionner le nappage chocolat de ses
cornets de glace 1 estimant est à peu
près fait sur ce principe la low cost au
mélange de chocolat noir et d'une huile
à laquelle en voir demander de figer
rapidement autour de l'internet
guy penche pour cet enrobage à base
d'huile de coco car comparé par exemple
à cet autre corner nappes et à l'huile
de tournesol la différence de texture
est flagrante
regardez ce qui se passe instantanément
au contact de la boule de glace et on
peut constater je veux dire que celui au
coco est relativement rigide et donc
forment effectivement une croûte autour
de la crème glacée tandis que celui
autour au tournesol a conservé une
consistance moelleuse et n'avons pas
enrobé correctement la crème de fait une
huile très utile le problème c'est que
les clients cherchent du gras certes
pratique à manipuler mais surtout pas
cher alors chaque jour devant son
ordinateur
philippe thierry doit chasser les bonnes
affaires
frédéric est ce que tu pourrais mettre
un petit mail avec le dernier
r cours des matières premières et voici
donc les cours du jour des huiles
végétales que monsieur thierry importe
du monde entier des graisses qu'il doit
acheter au plus bas car le prix est
susceptible de flamber au moindre
soubresaut de l'actualité internationale
moindre incident peut avoir une
influence à la baisse ou à la hausse sur
le prix des matières premières ça peut
être à typhon aux philippines qui donne
des problèmes pour les arbres à noix de
coco ça peut être un problème
météorologique pour les fruits de
d'épargner ses palmiers on en tire la
fameuse huile de palme
une huile produite en asie dans ces
immenses culture des arbres dont on
pressent la pulpe du fruit
une huile très bon marché
730 euros la tonne c'est 60 % moins
chère que l'huile de coco bien pratique
pour napper les cornets de glace
résultats philippe thierry glisse cette
huile de palme dans la plupart de ces
margarines en matière première
représente plus de 70% du prix du
produit fini et donc c'est un élément
extrêmement important sur lequel il faut
être humain attentif chaque jour une
huile de palme dont les industriels
raffole car en plus d'être pas cher elle
a un énorme avantage très recherché par
certains fabricants
il suffit de la comparer aux autres
huiles que l' usine travaille chaque
jour on voit là les différentes huiles
et graisses
en général quand vous utilisez une huile
à la maison elle est liquide
on constate que tout ce qu'on appelle
will de maïs huile de colza huile de
soja huile de tournesol et will
d'arachide sont au fait des produits
liquide à température ambiante
par contre quand on parle du huile de
palme ou will de graisse de coco on est
en présence de produits solides
une huile qui une fois mélangés à de
l'eau donne cette margarine que les
industriels glisse désormais dans la
moitié des produits en hypers au premier
rang les pâtes à tartiner depuis des
années la recette est toujours la même
en plus des 50 % de sucre la plupart des
marques ajoute en moyenne 20% ville de
pâles une huile indispensable dans la
recette car elle permet de conserver ses
pâtes à tartiner de longues semaines à
la maison sans les mettre au frigo cpo
affiche en effet une onctuosité très
apprécié des enfants au petit déjeuner
voilà pourquoi les rois du gras en
glisse aussi dans 70% des biscuits par
exemple une huile pâteuse comme du
beurre mais quatre fois moins cher
seulement il y a un revers à la médaille
cette huile que nous consommons tous a
mauvaise réputation
d'abord sa production est à l'origine
d'une déforestation effrayante comme en
attestent ces images en indonésie en
cinquante ans le pays a perdu plus de la
moitié de ces forêts car chaque minute
l'équivalent de six terrains de football
sont rasés pour laisser place à ses
champs de palmiers à perte de vue
une huile qui selon ses détracteurs
aurait aussi des effets néfastes sur
notre santé trop grasse elle
augmenterait les risques de maladies
cardiovasculaires à la clé crise
cardiaque artères bouchées
obésité pour autant les scientifiques ne
sont pas tous d'accord mais l'huile de
palme pointé du doigt de plus en plus de
grandes marques tentent de la remplacer
discrètement seulement c'est un vrai
cauchemar
[Musique]
notre enquête nous mène aux portes de
lyon dans les bureaux d'un grand
fabricant de l'alimentaire c'est
gwenaëlle qui est responsable de tous
les nouveaux produits lancés par cette
marque française fondée il ya 25 ans
céline marie nous sommes chez le leader
du bio en hypermarché gorgue une marque
consommée par une famille sur quatre en
france
l'enseigne vend ainsi plus d'un million
de paquets de biscuits chaque mois en
grande surface une marque bio qui se
sert en partie de l'huile de palme pour
l'élaboration de certains de ses
produits
parmi eux l'une de ses meilleures ventes
se fourrer à la framboise
un biscuit dont buena elle aimerait bien
retirer la fameuse huile
sauf que depuis toujours c'est un peu la
base de la recette des biscuits de la
marque car elles présentent beaucoup
davantage aujourd'hui c'est une huile
qui est neutre en bout qui qui apporte
une texture relativement agréable sur la
plupart des produits et surtout son
avantage majeur c'est qu'elle se
conserve bien dans le temps il va pas
développer de fausse note l apparence
here
donc c'est vraiment très utile
dans notre lit aujourd'hui mais pour
gwenaëlle la mauvaise réputation de
cette graisse végétale peut à tout
moment dissuader ses clients très
attaché au bio alors ce matin là elle va
tenter de donner la touche finale à une
nouvelle version de ce four et la
framboise
mais sans huile de palme la marque l'a
déjà supprimé dans 90 % de ses produits
mais à chaque fois c'est une vraie
galère pour se fourrer par exemple cela
fait deux ans que gwenaëlle il travaille
avec ses équipes
le paquet doit arriver en rayon l'été
prochain donc l'objectif de la
dégustation d'aujourd'hui ça va être de
vérifier que le produit la recette sans
huile de palme conserve toutes ses
qualités au bout de 10 mois voilà donc
c'est un c'est un point d'étape
essentielle et et je compte sur votre
dégustation aujourd'hui distribué le
biscuit sans huile de palme reste-t-il
aussi bon sur le garde dans un placard
jusqu'à la date limite de consommation
et puis c'est le dernier test d'une
longue série
pendant plusieurs mois gwenaëlle à
retravailler la recette avec d'autres
huiles moins bon que ce que la palme et
il ya eu de gros ratés comme celui ci
voilà ça c'est vraiment le biscuit
classique que l'on a aujourd'hui avec il
ya peu et voilà un essai par exemple qui
n'a pas été concluant qui a été fait
avec une huile complètement liquide
voyez il est pas tout à fait complet la
forme mais pas tout à fait la même on
n'a pas la même et pc en des biscuits là
on a une texture qui était de le voir
vraiment dur et aux goûts c'était la
catastrophe assurée auprès des clients
non plus très dur très dur à l'attack
est très dure en fait à la mastication
pas ça n'a vraiment rien à voir c'est
vraiment de produits complètement
différent et la différence n'est
vraiment pas acceptable
dans un rayon aussi concurrentiel que
les biscuits pas question de se rater
alors ce matin là cinq employés de la
marque vont goûter à l'aveuglé les deux
versions cachée sous des numéros le four
et à la framboise avec huile de palme et
la future recettes qui n'en contient
plus non immunes 347 puissant 23 les
deux doivent se ressembler en tous
points pour que le client ne vois aucune
différence en se jetant sur son paquet
de biscuits chaque détail est passé au
crible
ici on parle d'acidité du fourrage de
croustilles ans ou de free habilité
celui ci semble un petit peu plus sa
bleues c'est à dire que les petits
grains sont éparpillés un petit peu plus
dans la bouche plus facilement en fait
des petites différences que gwenaëlle
consignes scrupuleusement sur son
tableau comparatif et sont même trois
avaient une acidité qui arrivait un
petit peu plus tard jeune vaudais en
bouche fait le 347
mais après deux ans de travail le client
ne devrait y voir que du feu
en mangeant sont fourrées laframboise
sans huile de palme donc l'essentiel des
différences se situent au niveau de la
texture aujourd'hui donc on va lever
l'aveuglent donc c'est ce qu'on avait
dit on
d'accord la 123 la recette sans huile de
palme
une formule que gwenaëlle a concocté des
mois durant
un cocktail parfait dont elle ne compte
pas livré les secrets c'est énormément
de travail c'est une matière ce qui a
été développé spécifiquement pour nous
donc c'est un secret de fabrication que
l'on que nous avons bien que l'on veut
garder le plus possible
seul petit indice ce biscuit
contiendrait du beurre de cacao
une matière grasse aussi onctueuse que
l'huile de palme mais trois fois plus
onéreuses
résultat le four est la framboise de
gwenaëlle devrait coûter 5 à 10% plus
cher en rayon le prix à payer pour
manger plus sainement
si les fabricants prennent ainsi la
peine de modifier leurs recettes
c'est que les consommateurs sont de plus
en plus informés d'autant que les
industriels sont sous surveillance
aujourd'hui des contrôleurs des sortes
de gendarmes veillent à ce qu'il ne
dépasse pas les bornes
quitte à les censurer quand ils vont
trop loin en plein coeur de paris
voici le siège de l'autorité de
régulation de la publicité le gendarme
de la pub en france un organisme financé
par les géants de l'alimentaire
eux-mêmes pour veiller à ce que leurs
réclames respecte la loi en matière de
santé car pour attirer le client
la tentation est grande de franchir
certaines limites
ok à tout à l'heure salut c'est la
mission d'emilie le gall et de ses
collègues
pour cela ils s'installent
quotidiennement devant la télé comme
nous le faisons tous quatre heures en
moyenne par jour seulement au programme
ni film ni série ce qui les intéresse
c'est tout ce qui va se glisser entre
vos émissions préférées
la pub ce matin là emilie et son patron
stefan vont en regarder à la chaîne des
spots qui doivent bientôt passer à
l'écran on a cinquante deux films à
visionner ce m à chaque fois il scrute
un détail au bas de l'écran
ces petits messages de santé qui
viennent tempérer notre envies de
grignotage alors que des films nos plats
préférés les fameux pratiquer une
activité physique régulière ou manger au
moins cinq fruits et légumes par jour
des mentions obligatoires comme ici au
bas de cette pub de laitages pour
enfants
l'industriel a le choix entre une
quinzaine de formules annonceurs a fait
le choix ici de garder dans les mentions
sanitaire que la version qu'on appelle
adultes il existe aussi des versions
avec utilisant le tutoiement pour les
enfants des messages de santé au bas de
l'écran mais pas seulement pour
qu'émilie et stéphane donnent leur feu
vert avant la diffusion
les grandes marques doivent aussi
insérer des petits détails à l'image le
discrète incitation à manger sainement
comme ici en plein milieu de cette pub
pour un nouveau café au lait en
bouteille le début on voit au fond la
bouteille de lait avec des fruits
le fait qu'ils aient à l'arrière-plan
gambie le fruit est vraiment pas le
hasard c'est pour mon train
bon comportement alimentaire un petit
déjeuner équilibré donc là en
l'occurrence des règles strictes qui
encadrent ainsi les 450 pu visionner
chaque mois emilie et stéphane doit
veiller au moindre détail car il arrive
que les industriels franchissent la
ligne rouge
une dizaine de fois en moyenne chaque
année des manquements à la loi
voici quelques images de ces spots
recalé par l'autorité de la pub ici
un adolescent est sur le point d'aboutir
cette tartine nappé de chocolat en
poudre un petit déjeuner xxl tout sauf
équilibrer la réclame a été censuré
autre exemple avec sa bande de copains
ce fan de rugby se prend un apéro
saucisson devant la télé problème dans
une pub toute consommation devant un
écran est interdite
l'annonceur a dû revoir sa copie
derrière toutes ces règles il y à un
homme qui depuis des années ne cesse de
se battre pour trouver les moyens
d'alerté le consommateur sur ce qui est
bon ou pas pour notre santé
cet homme c'est un peu le cauchemar des
industriels de l'alimentaire le
professeur serge hercberg est l'un des
plus grands spécialistes de la nutrition
en france ce matin il a rendez vous dans
cet hôpital de la région parisienne pour
y donner une grande conférence car
depuis 2001 le professeur dirige tout le
programme national pour améliorer la
nutrition des français c'est lui par
exemple qui a inventé les fameux petits
messages de santé en bas de nos écrans
pub
l'objectif général améliorer l'état de
santé de l'ensemble de la population ce
matin devant une cinquantaine de jeunes
médecins venus l'écouter
serge hercberg martèle ses engagements
améliorer la qualité des aliments vendus
dans nos hypers car les français
consomment trop de sucre notamment si on
passe à 5 grammes par jour on réduire
est le taux global d'accident vasculaire
cérébral de près d'un quart et les taux
de maladies cardiovasculaires d'une
façon générale de 17%
sa dernière idée pour aider les français
à choisir au moment de remplir leurs
caddies ces petites étiquettes de
couleur un système de notation comme
pour la consommation électrique des
appareils électroménagers du vert au
rouge les couleurs évalue la qualité
nutritionnelle d'un dessert par exemple
une crème mont blanc qui va être jaune à
un flan caramel qui va être orange ou
une chocolat liégeois qui va être au
sujet c'est pas toujours évident d'être
capable de comparer ces produits donc
l'idée c'est vraiment des des
consommateurs à pouvoir juger entre des
produits de leurs qualités
nutritionnelles
en attendant que cela devienne une loi
certains ont déjà décidé de faire de ces
vignettes un nouveau système pour
permettre aux millions de consommateurs
que nous sommes de choisir correctement
les produits que nous voulons acheter
et concrètement pour le mettre au point
voilà ce que ça donne
[Musique]
nous sommes en plein paris à chaque fois
qu'il fait ses courses
ce consommateur pas tout à fait comme
les autres à une drôle de manie
dans son supermarché stéphane gigandet
prend en photo tous les produits qu'ils
croisent en rayon on prend le coda est
ce qui nous intéresse le plus
l'étiquette l'étiquette au dos du paquet
avec toutes les teneur en gras en sel ou
en sucre
c'est la seule indication quant on veut
manger sainement et comparer par exemple
plusieurs paquets de céréales seulement
difficile de s'y retrouver au milieu de
tous ces chiffres beaucoup de
pourcentage dans tous les sens même un
expert en nutrition serait perdue face à
tous ces tableaux s'il devait en
quelques minutes nous dire lequel de ces
produits est le plus sain sur un plan
nutritionnel et voilà donc pourquoi
stéphane prend toutes ces étiquettes en
photo car la prochaine fois qu'il
viendra au supermarché il saura quelle
céréales choisir grâce à une petite
application ça
en effet une fois revenu chez lui ce
père de famille ingénieur en
informatique et passionnée de cuisine va
passer ces étiquettes à la moulinette
d'un logiciel qu'il a créé il ya deux
ans on va pouvoir sélectionner pour
recadrer la photo sur son site gratuit
plus de 18000 produits sont ainsi
recensés
grâce à la participation d'un millier de
consommateurs comme lui armés de leurs
appareils photos c'est les produits
qu'on a ajouté tout à l'heure au
supermarché dont on a pris les photos
mais voilà le plus étonnant grâce à un
petit logiciel de reconnaissance de
caractères stéphane enregistre
automatiquement toutes les données des
étiquettes et en quelques secondes
son site attribue une note à chaque
produit de a pour les plus sains à e
pour les moins bons ce qu'on obtient
c'est un peu comme un bulletin de notes
pour les produits malheureusement celui
là obtenu la moins bonne note peut en
fait stéphane a tout simplement appliqué
à la lettre le système de vignettes de
couleurs proposées par le professeur
hercberg
l'équipe du professeur nous a transmis
la formule qui permet de calculer cette
note en fonction du taux de sel les
graisses saturées est léché des fibres
et du coup on a calculé la note pour
tous les produits qui sont dans la base
de données une notation qui réserve
quelques surprises
par exemple avec ce paquet de biscuits
apéritifs light vendus dans une grande
surface discount avec la mention allégé
en matières grasses
résultat un e la plus mauvaise note
moi si je suis consommateur je vois un
produit les jeunes grèce lee bon ben on
attendait donc ce qui est toujours
intéressant c'est d'aller voir à quoi
correspond le petit astérisque qui juste
après allégé en matières grasses souvent
s'est allégé en matières grasses par
rapport à la moyenne des autres produits
de la même catégorie
ça ne veut pas forcément dire qu'il ya
très peu de matières grasses mais alors
certains biscuits apéritifs font-ils
mieux la meilleure note 1 c revient
assez cracker sauce soja et pommes de
terre vendu quatre fois plus cher que
les précédents comme souvent les
consommateurs à petit budget doivent y
mettre le prix pour manger plus simple
mais stéphane espère tout de même que sa
dotation va faire bouger les industriels
on espère justement que là ça va pousser
les industriels les fabricants à
proposer pas des meilleurs produits à
changer un peu les alizés ingrédients
pour peut-être passé de d à c ou 2 c à b
pourquoi pas donné
des industriels qui pour l'heure
s'opposent à ces codes couleurs alors
même que de plus en plus de
consommateurs demandent à être mieux
informés mais pourquoi les firmes de
l'agroalimentaire sont elles si
réticente pour obtenir une réponse à
cette question nous nous sommes rendus à
orléans il y a quelques semaines un
grand salon y était organisé avec tous
les poids lourds du secteur notamment
pour aborder la question des bonnes
pratiques en matière de santé dans les
rayons
au premier rang des intervenants jean
philippe girard le patron de l'ania le
très puissant lobby des géants de
l'alimentaire alors serait-il d'accord
pour afficher la qualité nutritionnelle
de nos plats préférés avec les fameuses
petites étiquettes de couleur du
professeur hercberg
manifestement les industriels ne sont
pas prêts à jouer le jeu c'est très
stigmatisant pour moi très clairement
quelqu'un qui se nourrira que deux
verres aura un des guides nutritionnelle
nos produits sont ici de deux siècles de
savoir faire on prend les fromages les
charcuteries le miel tous ces métiers
effectivement contiennent du sucre du
gras du sel et donc feront l'objet
obligatoirement d'une pastille rouge et
le rouge vous savez ce que ça veut dire
c'est la sanction immédiate
transformer un repenser corps
nutritionnels pour moi cette c'est
impensable
on tuerait des siècles de savoir faire
et ce que le monde entier vient chercher
et c'est à dire notre modèle alimentaire
français
pourtant d'ici deux ans un nouvel
étiquetage nutritionnel doit voir le
jour
une étiquette claire et lisible commune
à toute l'europe pour permettre aux
consommateurs de comparer et de manger
plus sainement
en attendant le business ne s'est jamais
aussi bien portée pour les dix plus
grands industriels mondiaux de
l'alimentaire chaque jour ils vendent
pour un milliard d'euros de leurs
produits dans nos rayons
[Musique]